I never thought the day would come in which
I would make a full-fledged devoid of logic
video for an MCU movie. There would always be some
silly aspects for Marvel movies, but never enough
to the point of justifying an entire video.
However, I think Antman Quantumania is one of
the most stupid MCU movies to the point where
the devoid of logic aspects were overflowing.
Within the first 10 minutes of the movie, it
immediately requires a major contrivance for
the entire story to exist. And that contrivance
is Janet Van Dyne not telling anyone about an
extremely dangerous enemy in the quantum realm.
Even when Cassie Lang brings out a Quantum device
that can send a signal down there, she
doesn’t warn them about Kang. Instead,
she just acts like an unjustified crazy person and
half haphazardly pulls the power on this device as
if it were my mom unplugging my PC at 1am while
I’m playing Minecraft. It’s kind of wild here
that she isn’t open and explains her reasoning.
These are all rational people and they would most
likely listen to Janet’s warnings given that she
lived down there for many years. The writer tries
to play it off as Janet not wanting to go into
it because she’s ashamed of the bad things she’s
done and probably thinks she can get away with
not telling them about Kang. Which news alert,
you live in a family that’s obsessed with the
Quantum realm and actively wants to explore it,
so you should probably give them some warnings.
It’s an inevitable conflict that you can’t ignore.
So yeah, it’s obviously this way so that we can
have this malfunction and I honestly feel like it
would be better if Cassie Lang made a design flaw
and that’s why they get sucked into the Quantum
realm. Because when you think about it, Cassie
Lang has to be absurdly smart for being able to
make this, regardless of having Hank’s journals.
Like her intellect is kind of swept under the rug
and maybe the writer should have explored the
carelessness of Cassie Lang wanting to make a
contribution to society, and the mounting pressure
of her family all being heroes. So maybe she cut
corners and rushes along this tech so that she
could feel validated in this family that’s hard to
live up to, given their massive accomplishments.
Personally, I feel like this already gives Cassie
Lang more depth as a character instead of just
being a generic good-doer who basically has no
flaws. Besides her getting arrested at a protest,
which really isn’t a flaw. Have her deal with the
consequences of sending her loved ones to the
Quantum realm and have her rise to the occasion
and save them. That’s a proper hero's journey.
This actually gives her a tangible character arc
and if I were to ask you what her arc for the
movie currently is, you’d probably struggle.
Moving along into the Quantum realm, this entire
setting is extremely confusing and inconsistent.
Or it lacks any semblance of logic because the
writer doesn’t make an attempt at explaining
anything within the quantum realm. Some things
are explained, but there’s just so much random
shit that’s constantly happening in every scene
that it turns the movie into a silly mess. Now
this wouldn’t really bother me, but the MCU is
pretty fleshed out overall and is based in logic.
Like you can generally explain anything that has
happened in the past with complete understanding.
So the issue with this movie is that they
go full-blown into wacky territory and it
feels jarring for the tone. I just have so many
questions like how are they even breathing here,
why are there aliens that look like broccoli,
what is the science behind these floating ships,
anything regarding populations, how they
even live, how they’re making these cities,
and really I can keep going on but you get it.
It feels like Antman Quantumania turned into Rick
and Morty which isn't a coincidence because the
writer for the movie came from that show. However,
all the silly and unexplained sy-fy elements in
Rick and Morty are fine because the show never
takes itself that seriously. Which I guess
Quantumania is trying to be more humorful,
but it normally falls flat in my
opinion, and is always kind of awkward.
In essence, the entire Quantum realm just feels
like an excuse to throw whatever the writer wants
on screen, and then for any potential explanation,
they’ll stamp the word quantum in front of it.
So basically the entire setting for the movie
is devoid of logic, but it is by design.
So getting back to the story, Scott and Cassie
are split up from the Van Dyne dysfunctional
family team and they get attacked by Kang’s army
while they’re with some rebels. What happens
here is probably one of the most unappealing fight
sequences visually which is really sad considering
that the environment they’re in essentially has
endless possibilities for how it could look,
but for some reason, it looks really dull. During
this fight scene, it’s revealed that Cassie has
her own suit, which is immediately confusing
because she’s been in life-threatening scenarios
on multiple occasions earlier on, and for some
reason, she chooses to not activate her suit.
She had to be saved by her father while free
falling, they got chased by a massive alien,
and she ran around during this action scene in
normal clothes for an unnecessarily long time.
Why is this the case? Because we wouldn’t have
this totally awesome suit reveal moment. It’s also
kind of funny that Scott and Cassie have an entire
educational interaction about using the suit while
literally being in the middle of the battlefield.
But luckily Kang’s androids are comically
ineffective. At the end of the scene, MODOK gets
revealed, and writing-wise, it’s really sad that
he’s a constant punching bag for jokes. It really
undercuts the severity of the situation and it’s
really hard to feel a sense of danger when this
comical face is staring at you. Visually I’m
surprised they didn’t try to make the design of
the face more unhuman-like or is more malformed,
instead of just enlarging it. It looks ridiculous
and this character design decision is devoid of
logic to me. I understand that it’s supposed to
be a big head, but it feels like their intentions
were making MODOK look funny on purpose since the
writing surrounding him constantly degrades him
for humor. Like I wish I could unsee this shot of
his ass, and I do not appreciate being visually
assaulted. This is just the visual side of
things and his story later on gets laughably bad.
Looking over at the Van Dyne family, their
journey doesn’t really have much impact on
the overall plot and is mostly the director or
writer playing out their fantasy of making a
star wars movie. In Quantumania though, the
things that happen are so bizarre that they
are straight-up confounding or cringe-inducing.
Like this random interaction in the desert where
Janet cuts off an alien’s arm which buys her a
ship, this broccoli alien trying to hit on Hope,
and the controls of this alien ship having
condom joysticks that Hank miraculously
knows how to fly. At this point, I assume
the writer doesn’t care about any of this
making sense and is batting away the notion
of logic under the guise of comedy. But I
don’t really find this funny in any way and
am constantly in a wtf expression. Also,
there’s this really weird dialogue interaction
that is so awkward that I don’t know how it made
it into the final script. I wonder if Michael
Douglas had an existential crisis while reading
the script and saw this dialogue paired with him
getting sucked off by two alien fleshlights. So
all of these scenes are essentially driven by the
mystery of who this unknown traveler was at the
beginning of the movie. And this mystery is the
opposite of intriguing because everyone in the
audience already knows that it’s Kang and what he
does. Janet is basically teasing this mega threat
at the end of every scene and it’s so dumb because
why wouldn’t she just tell Hope and Hank earlier.
Why wait so long? They were literally walking
in an alien forest for a while with not much
to do. Also during Janet’s info dump about her
past with Kang, she reveals that the multiverse
is real to Hank. Which is again kind of weird
that she would withhold this crazy scientific
revelation from her husband who would love to know
about that. She has all of this reality-altering
scientific information that she can do so much
good with that she for some reason withholds.
Now that Kang is finally revealed in the
narrative, that means we can have a scene
between him and Scott. There’s nothing wrong with
this scene and I just wanted to point it out as
being one of the few good scenes in the movie. It
feels like whiplash going from all the goofy shit
that was happening to this scene, but hell I’ll
take any ounce of Kang at this rate to move away
from the annoying comedy. From here Kang threatens
to kill Cassie if Scott doesn’t shrink down the
power source for his ship that Janet exploded.
He obviously agrees and this scene is kind of
interesting, but there are still multiple things
about it that don’t make sense. For starters,
Scott is in a possibility field that splits
himself whenever he is met with making a
decision. This exponentially goes out of control
and in this crowd, a Baskin Robins Scott shows up.
Which obviously is impossible given that all of
these versions derive from his current self. So
the writer is making a joke that completely breaks
the logic of the scene. They then eventually work
together and act like a colony of ants. Which
thematically is cool, but at no point is this a
clever solution because it’s completely detached
from basic physics. Finally, this World War Z
stack of zombies falls down and Hope flies in
to rescue Scott just in time, how convenient.
Then together all their possible selves combine
back into themselves, which isn’t explained and
I have no idea why that happened. But they both
shoot shrinking Pym particles into the core and
it shrinks. Now this is immediately inconsistent
to what just happened before because Scott fired
a Pym particle and it did absolutely nothing to
the surface. But heyyyy, if we fire like twenty
of them at different points of the surface then
surely that would work. Which it somehow does and
it’s also convenient that it shrinks down to
the exact size that they needed it to be. If
they shot it with twenty and it actually worked
this time then wouldn't it have shrunken down
significantly smaller than what it is now? Janet
only enlarged it with 4 pym particles, so the math
doesn’t add up, or the barrier just so happened
to negate the perfect amount of pym particles for
the math to check out. Whatever, there’s so many
questions that you have to ignore to enjoy this.
After this, Kang gets the power source for his
ship and instead of instantly plugging it in and
leaving, he decides to give a villain monologue to
Janet. Which is probably one of the most classic
villain tropes at this point and is kind of
funny that Marvel movies are still doing this
31 movies in. Not including the TV shows. During
this monologue, Kang wants to know what Janet
saw when she touched the neural link on his ship.
Which allowed her to see his memories or whatever.
However, it seemed pretty clear what she saw in
the past, and basically said she saw him destroy
planets and timelines. But for some reason, Kang
wants to know the specifics I guess? I don’t know.
This is obviously happening to stall for time
and Kang also makes a speech to his androids,
which these are androids I’m pretty sure, and I
don’t understand why he would need to make this
speech to them. Or why he would even care about
the rest of the population of the Quantum realm.
Just freaking leave my dude. Not to mention that
you left Scott and Hope alive to come back and
attack you. You’ve literally been waiting for
this moment for years and you’re delaying your
own departure. Also, a funny little moment during
Kang and Janet’s interaction was that she said
trillions of people will die due to timelines
as a whole getting deleted. Now I’m pretty sure
that number would be astoundingly bigger than
trillions given that we're talking about the
universe here. If Earth almost has a population
of 8 billion people then I’m sure we’d be getting
into numbers higher than the trillions. This was
just one tiny interaction that doesn’t matter.
Right after this, Cassie is being escorted back to
her cell, and by some massive oversight from Kang,
he didn’t take away her Pym particles or even her
suit and she escapes. That would be like taking
Iron Man prisoner and leaving him in his suit to
where he could fly away at any moment. The second
this happened in the theater I was shocked by how
lazy the writing was here. It was also funny how
she enlarged one of the androids and this group
of guards coming down the hallway doesn’t see
him I guess? Also, she shrinks down in plain
view of this group of guards walking towards
her. So to add to the incompetent bad guy army
list, they are blind, have slow reaction times,
and have terrible aim. They are starting to
sound like something very familiar. Which
since I’m already making this comparison with
Star Wars, Kang and MODOK are basically like
Palpatine and Darth Vader. Especially since Kang
can use the force and utilizes energy beams.
Coincidence? I think not! Then like 5 minutes
later Janet also escapes captivity by herself.
At this point in the movie, I completely gave
up because if they refuse to put any handcuffs
on their prisoners and there’s basically no
ramifications to being caught, then there
is no danger for these characters. The fact that
the writer did this twice is flat-out insulting.
Hank Pym gets attacked by MODOK while in the
fleshlight ship and it crashlands. Luckily though,
MODOK doesn’t even bother to check if Hank
is alive and doesn’t confirm the kill.
Kind of betrays the name of MODOK since his name
stands for Mechanized Organism Designed Only for
Killing. So not even checking to see if a target
who he also hates is actually dead is wild. When
Hank gets out of the crash he finds his colony of
smart ants that got sucked into the Quantum Realm
at the start of the movie. It’s revealed here
that the ants went through a time dilation zone
that made it to where they lived thousands of
years in a single day. They created an advanced
civilization and are now a thriving society who
seeked out Hank to save him. This is probably the
most convenient thing I’ve ever seen in a movie
and now the good guys have an ant army out of
nowhere. A literal deus ex machina that they try
to downplay as being clever since Hank got random
transmissions in his hearing aid or whatever.
But with so much random nonsense happening
throughout the movie, it’s hard to take anything
as being foreshadowing. Also, these Quantum Realm
mechanics are really inconsistent. There’s just
time dilation pockets in random areas. Going back
to Cassie, she breaks out the leader of the
rebels and they hatch a plan to hijack Kang’s
broadcast to tell everyone to rebel. There’s a
couple minor things here that are questionable
like Cassie not knowing how to open the cell
and luckily smashes a guard's face into it,
which opens it. Although this is contradicted
five minutes later when the rebel leader inputs
a code into a panel that unlocks it. Not sure how
she knows that but ok. And the other thing being
that they somehow know where the broadcasting
room is in this foreign compound. If I can barely
navigate Hogwarts with a dedicated map in the
bottom left of my screen then I don’t know how
they could find a very specific room in this
massive building. That they’ve also never been
in before. Unless if there’s just a convenient
map on the wall marking the broadcasting room.
Kang then sends MODOK after Cassie and
he eventually bests her and is able to
kill her. But wait, she has plot armor and
MODOK decides not to kill her and instead
gets distracted by Scott walking around in the
background. Like this is a guaranteed way to
not make anyone care about your action when
you know there will be no consequences. The
even crazier thing is that this happens again
and MODOK chooses to talk to Cassie instead
of killing her. Like I just don’t care
anymore. Then she turns big and wrecks
MODOK. Their following scene together is
probably the worst scene in the entirety
of the MCU. I’m not exaggerating because I
genuinely can’t think of a worse scene than
this. Just don’t be a dick 4head.
And then he turns into a good guy,
like WHATTTT!? Him sacrificing himself and
quote on quote becoming an avenger is such
a bizarre turn of events. Especially with how
they treat his death scene. It’s so awkward,
it tries to be funny when it clearly isn’t,
and then the music climaxes as an attempt to
punctuate this scene as being a big moment
when it’s not. At this point in the theater
when originally watching it I looked over at
my girlfriend in complete shock and we were
just like what are we even watching right now. I
want to put you into the mind space of Darryn aka
MODOK. This is a man who hated and was trying
to kill Antman and in the process got banished
to the quantum realm. This turned him into a
disfigured monster and the amount of resentment
towards Scott for doing this must of have been
unimaginable. Kang then manipulated this man into
becoming a weapon and he massacred thousands of
people and even loved doing so. His mental state
should be long gone from killing people for
so long and should not be salvageable by any
degree. So the fact that he even has this arc, to
begin with, is absurd. I don’t think there is any
realistic angle in which you could give MODOK, a
being so filled with rage and revenge for so long,
a redemption arc. And it’s even crazier that to
change his mind, a character just tells him not
to be a dick. And that is what made him change
his entire motivation. Jesus Christ I can’t.
So finally we arrive to some Kang carnage and
through his showcase here, this is probably one of
the most glaring examples of nerfing your villain
in real time. He starts out completely wiping
the floor with these rebels in which if this blue
beam touches them they instantly go poof. However,
when he fights Ant-man and friends if he shoots
them with his beam of disintegration or whatever
that I assume like erases them from time,
they just get knocked back. So right away,
it isn’t consistent despite these two events
happening minutes apart. And I don’t believe their
suits should be stopping this since they aren’t
made by vibranium or anything. Also, Kang has the
literal force and doesn’t use it a single time.
Along with being able to fly around on a platform.
Like couldn’t he force-hold the three of them here
in this one spot instead of giving yet another
villain monologue? Then he gets overwhelmed by
Hank’s ant army and Kang doesn’t use his abilities
logically. When Kang could use any of his
powers like flying away from the ants to safety,
erasing them all with his energy beam that cuts
through people like paper, or even just force
pushing away ants, it’s crazy that he instead
opts to throw up a force shield that isn’t viable
to keep up at all times. This is supposed to be an
Avengers-level threat and he lost to motherfucking
ants, man. That is by far the biggest buzzkill
I’ve ever seen. I went into this movie hyped to
see a menacing and crazy villain who’s extremely
powerful, but all I got was a buffoon who lost to
ants. How the hell did this man conquer a galaxy
and best the military strengths of entire worlds
when he can’t even overcome an army of ants who
can only melee him up close. We only got to see
him fight for like a few minutes and in that
time it was a mess from a writing standpoint.
After this battle, Janet opens up a portal from
Kang’s device back to their homeworld. They all
get out but just as Scott is about to step in he
chooses to stay behind and stop Kang from getting
to Earth. The following fight is actually good and
is very visceral. It shows the immense strength
of Kang and for once this scene actually made
me respect him as a villain. He’s obliterating
Scott in hand-to-hand combat and this was really
one of the only things the movie got right. Scott
realizes that he has no chance and corrupts the
power source fueling the portal and Hope comes
back to help Scott defeat Kang. Now this was
a pretty powerful ending at the moment because
it was as if Scott was destroying his only way
home and his life with his daughter to defeat
the villain. For once, an action has drastic
consequences. But nope, that notion is instantly
disregarded because Cassie Lang is a brainiac and
somehow fixes the portal in like one minute flat.
This essentially robs the ending from any sort
of impact for me because it erases the weight
of this major decision to destroy his only way
home. So the heroes live happily ever after.
The council of Kangs does make
me excited for upcoming movies,
but given all the controversy around
Jonathan Majors, I’m not sure what his
future in the MCU is going to look like.
So yeah, that was Ant-Man Quantumania.
I’m sorry this video is so delayed. My channel
got demonetized so I held on to this video
for over a month and waited to release it. I
already reapplied and made a lot of changes,
but I was still denied, so I’m going to
make nothing off of YouTube for the next
3 months. Since I can’t reapply until September.
To combat this, I’m starting a Patreon and I would
love your support. You can chip in whatever
you want and I’m grateful in advance if you
choose to support me. It’s honestly scary to
rely on YouTube financially and then for them
to suddenly pull the plug with no warning.
I’ll leave a link in the description and
more details about Patreon in the comments. Thank
you for watching as always and have a good day.